hey guys so the Vision Pro has been out
for a little while now and I wanted to
show you what I have in my vision Pro
bag actually YouTube sent me this
backpack and I'm absolutely obsessed
with it it's by Tumi it is so nice the
only problem is I really can only fit
the Vision Pro and some other
accessories in here I can't fit anything
else in it it's basically Vision Pro bag
or bus but this is now my to go bag if I
do want to take Vision Pro around and
out this is what I've got so let's check
it out now the first thing because you
can connect keyboard and a mouse to it I
can't fit my MacBook in here if the
Vision Pro is in here so I've packed a
keyboard and a trackpad this also has
some really nice little zipper pulls on
it it's like the perfect backpack I
think it just needs to be a little bit
bigger if I want to put more things in
it here she is it fits perfectly like it
is an absolute perfect fit so this is
the official Apple Vision Pro bag as you
can see it's got Vision Pro the Little
Apple logo it's got this nice little
handle for a carrying case feels pretty
substantial it's also pretty heavy cuz
I've put a few other things in here as
well let's open it up see here's the
case I've got my battery pack here that
goes into Vision Pro it's nicely all
packed in just like that and of course
we have Vision Pro all nicely tucked
away but let me show you what I've got
in this bag I also have another anchor
battery packed right here which is great
cuz I do have a lot of extra space that
I can still put a few things in I huge
thank you to Anor for partnering with me
on a portion of this video I got got to
show you some of these new goodies that
I got from Anker it's so nice because
this little baggie comes with the case
and I can fit so much other stuff in
here like look at all this stuff I have
in here I am such a huge fan of anchor I
have so many different battery packs and
cables from them they make such amazing
stuff to power all of your Tech this is
something that I don't leave home
without if I'm traveling this is the
anchor Mago wireless charging station
and it's a foldable 3 in one that can
charge my phone airpods and Apple watch
all at the same time it's also got Apple
certified fast charging for the Apple
watch which is perfect if I need to get
a little boost plus it's also a perfect
setup for the new standby mode on the
iPhone 15 and iOS 17 it looks perfect on
any desk whether it's a hotel or here at
my home office plus I just love the
design of this thing it's super Compact
and everything folds up into this nice
little package it's perfect now of
course I am always on the go so I'm
going to need some power to take with me
now I've got these two anchor Mago power
Banks this is the 6.6k version it has a
6600 m amp hour battery capacity and it
has this awesome folding design it's got
20 W USBC two-way charging plus it will
still charge your phone while it's
plugged in which is great and I also
have the 10K version which has a massive
10,000 mamp battery capacity the same
awesome foldable stand design which I
love and the best part is it has a smart
display so you can monitor the battery
levels at a glance and I actually need
to charge this so we're going to plug
you in I also love that Mago works with
with apple mag safe and has 15 watt
charging so you know you're going to be
getting super fast charge times thank
you to ankor for sponsoring a portion of
this video These are never leaving my
bag again now I also have been carrying
with me the USBC cable that came with it
the power brick and also some of the new
USBC airpods because one of the new
things with the new airpods is you can
actually listen to spatial audio with
the Apple Vision Pro now you can only do
that with the new USBC version you'll
still get incredible audio with any of
the other airpods but if you do have
this and you link it to the new USBC
airpods like spatial video is one thing
but spatial audio honestly sets this
apart from like anything because it
makes you really immersed in whatever
experiences that you're experiencing so
if this is the first time you're seeing
Apple Vision Pro hi here it is I have
posted many videos about it already so
I'm sure you are well aware of what
we're about to see I really like the way
that they have made this little cover
Like It just fits perfectly on it I have
my polishing cloth oh no I have no idea
where my polishing cloth is you guys I'm
so sad no it's in here I totally missed
it I almost had a freak out let's clean
you up she is shining
shimmering so so
Splendid I do really love this little
travel kit it's so easy to put
everything into I will be excited to see
some third party ones cuzz like
obviously this one is very expensive I
can't wait until Vision Pro has been out
for longer and there's a bunch of really
fun third party ones that I can check
out because this is a nice case but I do
feel like once you've paid so much money
for the Apple Vision Pro you might want
to cut a break somewhere so hopefully
there'll be some less expensive cases
out there all that to be said though the
case is really nice like it's so soft
and you really can fit a lot into it
like I fit all my Chargers in here it's
perfect everything that I need I could
even fit a snack in here if I
wanted and now back into the bag we go
it's such a great backpack but I can't
fit anything else but Vision Pro like
it's perfect for it though on the go
like there's so many fun little details
it's even got this little pouch in here
if it starts raining water resistant
like we're set thank you guys for
watching if you'd like to see me cover
anything else Vision Pro related please
leave it in the comments or or send me a
message public message on X it's still a
tweet in my heart be sure to subscribe
so you'll know when I post new videos
I've got a bunch more coming up so I
look forward to sharing those with you
I'll see you then bye